Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
There are many research projects about teaching
an AI to play video games well.
We have seen some amazing results from DeepMind's
Deep Q Learning algorithm that performed on
a superhuman level on many games, but faltered
on others.
What really made the difference is the sparsity
of rewards and the lack of longer-term planning.
What this means is that the more often we
see the score change on our screen, the faster
we know how well we are doing and change our
strategy if needed.
For instance, if we make a mistake in Atari
Breakout, we lose a life almost immediately,
but in a strategy game, a bad decision may
come back to haunt us up to an hour after
committing it.
So, what can we do to build an AI that can
deal with these cases?
So far when we have talked about extrinsic
rewards that come from the environment, for
instance, our score in a video game, and most
existing AIs are for all intents and purposes,
extrinsic score-maximizing machines.
And this work is about introducing an intrinsic
reward by endowing an AI with one of the most
humanlike attributes: curiosity.
But hold on right there, how can a machine
possibly become curious?
Well, curiosity is defined by whatever mathematical
definition we attach to it.
In this work, curiosity is defined as the
AI's ability to predict the results of its
own actions.
This is big, because it gives the AI tools
to pre-emptively start learning skills that
don't seem useful now, but might be useful
in the future.
In short, this AI is driven to explore, even
if it hasn't been told how well it is doing.
It will naturally start exploring levels in
Super Mario, even without seeing the score.
And now comes the great part: this curiosity
really teaches the AI to learn new skills,
and when we drop it into a new, previously
unseen level, it will perform much better
than a non-curious one.
When playing Doom, the legendary first-person
shooter game, it will also start exploring
the level and is able to rapidly solve hard
exploration tasks.
The comparisons reveal that an AI infused
with curiosity performs significantly better
on easier tasks, but the even cooler part
is that with curiosity, we can further increase
the difficulty of the games and the sparsity
of external rewards and can expect the agent
to do well, even when previous algorithms
failed.
This will be able to play much harder games
than previous works.
And remember, games are only used to demonstrate
the concept here, this will be able to do
so much more.
Love it.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!